So the first one, from a computational perspective, NP-complete problems
are the hardest ones out there.
This is actually false. There are much harder problems.
For example, problems that are in the complexity class P space,
or exponential space, or any number of other complexity classes.
The second one is also false.
P=NP would not imply that all NP-complete problems are solvable in practice.
We might still have huge polynomials.
For instance, we might have a polynomial that is n to some very, very large number,
and in practice this is still not going to be solvable.
P=NP isn't necessarily going to imply that we can solve these problems in practice.
The third statement is true.
All NP-complete problems are solvable in polynomial time on a nondeterministic RAM.
That's more or less the definition of what it means for a problem to be an NP.